we should also mention we're playing
tavern music before this and which i
love which i first when i think you have
to stop the tavern music yeah because it
doesn't the the audio okay okay but it
makes yeah it'll make the podcast
no one will want to listen to the
podcast they probably would but it makes
me it reminds me like a video game like
a role-playing video game where you have
experience points there's something
really
joyful
about wandering places like elder
scrolls
like skyrim just exploring
uh these landscapes in another world and
then you get experience points and you
can work on different skills and somehow
you progress in life
and i don't know it's simple it doesn't
have some of the messy complexities of
life and there's usually a bad guy you
can fight in in um in skyrim it's
dragons and so on i'm sure in elder ring
there's a bunch of monsters you can
fight i love that i feel like elden ring
i i feel like this is a good analogy to
music protection though because it's
like i feel like the engineers and the
people creating these open worlds are
it's sort of like similar to people to
music producers whereas it's like this
this hidden archetype that like no one
really understands what they do and no
one really knows who they are but
they're like
it's like the artist engineer because
it's like
it's both art and
fairly complex engineering
you